dix-sept fois avec un allègement
partielle des restrictions sanitaires le
comité scientifique annonce la fin du
couvre-feu mais recommande le maintien
de l'interdiction de manifester est
justement de nombreux rassemblements
sont prévus cette semaine pour protester
contre les décisions du président tayeb
et les mesures exceptionnelles à tunis
notre correspondant bassam chebbi c'est
une annonce qui était attendue par les
tunisiens le couvre-feu instauré le 13
janvier dernier de 22h à 5h du matin
pour lutter contre la recrudescence des
cas de kobe de 19 dans le pays pourrait
prendre fin dès ce jeudi à l'issue de sa
réunion de mardi les membres du comité
scientifique ont déclaré qu'au vu du
nombre décroissant des nouveaux cas
certaines mesures seront allégé le
couvre-feu suspendu dans une déclaration
accordée à nos confrères de l'agencé
tunisie afrique presse le docteur grafu
ce membre du comité scientifique de
lutte contre le corps la virus a indiqué
qu'il pourrait revenir sur cette
décision à tout moment écoutez ces
recommandations pourraient être révisées
selon l'évolution de la situation
épidémique dans le pays appelons les
citoyens se faire administrer la
troisième dose de rappel pour la
maîtrise de la situation épidémique et
de la contagion par le virus le
couvre-feu est levé mais pas
l'interdiction de manifester ou de se
rassembler dans un pays où les
protestations ne cessent de croître a
malgré l'interdiction plusieurs
manifestations sont prévues cette
semaine à commencer par celles des
magistrats ce jeudi elle fait suite à la
dissolution du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature une autre mobilisation est
organisée dimanche par le parti ennahdha
contre les mesures exceptionnelles du
président sayyed lé ministère tunisien
de la santé a annoncé mardi avoir
recensé 5122 nouvelles contaminations
variant omicron pour un taux de
positivité de 33,6 % contre 37 9% il y a